we're going i do want everyone to see
what's going on I want everyone to see
the abuse that I endure on abuse behind
closed doors you guys people say that
I'm hard on Benton you missed the last
20 minutes of him berating me who says
that someone just farted was that you
no it was one of these 18 dolls
[Laughter]
I was just cat called by Benton can't
call call down I called you out told me
to put on eyeliner
oh wait a scare or whatever and then you
in the bathroom and tricked it put on
just the tip of your lash yeah I don't
want I don't your I don't need to be in
your male gaze
you're not 13 years old you can't just
pencil blue eyeliner on your eye and be
like I'm ready ready to go what is wrong
with just a berry lip who are you me me
from The Drew Carey Show what are you
doing ah not okay well look I do think
that it's important that we address stop
screwing around and address the biggest
news story in the world right now what
everyone's talking about which is my
blue eyeliner it's all anyone's talking
about me love individuality it's really
the Internet as a buzz my comments are
just a flame look I have not been out of
my house in three my California is shut
down and my style evolution has become
very iconic very quickly the problem
with when you're at home and don't go
anywhere you don't have anyone to check
you you don't have anyone to mock you
you don't have anyone to give you like a
weird look so I've just fully started
dressing in wolf sweatshirts blue
eyeliner it's just it's it's alarming
like three months ago I was like maybe I
should buy this vintage horse shirt now
it's just like walk I can't wear my
coral necklace without my tiger's eye
earrings yeah you just turned into it
like the party planner at a retirement
home I just you have gay pink eye now
it's just ever-changing think that this
blue eyeliner is my brand now this is my
blue eyeliner is like Gallagher's
watermelon at this point this is I a
conic so I do feel like my fashion I
don't know maybe I'm going through
something what's going on in the news in
the world like I'm having some kind of
emotional reaction to or I feel like I
need to really go for it
with my fashion sense but I'm a little
bit alarmed in the decisions I make I
mean the other day I was like I can't
wear my feather earrings my tutus at the
dry cleaner this doesn't match at all
like I literally was like I can't wear
my muumuu without my tiara that would
look ridiculous I do think though that
the blue eyeliner is maybe in reaction
to wearing masks we also wear masks and
I feel like it's I'm not able to
communicate or something like I'm not
like I need to tell a story I guess with
my eyes cuz it's the only thing that's
showing you want people to know you're
like if I didn't have this mask on I'd
have something to say I need you to know
I want you to know that I take up a lot
of space with or without this mask like
I think that now that some of my
personality is hidden I no need to let
people know that I'm unpredictable in
other nonverbal ways I'm wild you know I
I do believe strongly I think this was
in the 48 laws of power was that how
many loads of power there were I think
it was one of them was you always need
to come off a little crazy and a little
unpredictable so people don't fuck with
you nailed it and I haven't yet got a
teardrop tattoo so I feel like that's
what my blue eyeliner is convey that is
you people come into the house to fix
the furnace or something and you're
wearing full dog pajamas and blue
eyeliner at the door you have a David
Bowie lightning bolt down your face
you're like come in I'm like steal for
me I dare ya want to go in the Attic go
for it I think when you're a woman that
lives alone and you have like people
coming into your house to do work you
have to make sure they know that you're
batshit crazy I have to be a fairy
people come and do work at my house in
the middle of nowhere like any of these
workers could murder me at any time but
they're like I'm they're gonna think
twice after they look at my eyelids she
carries a switchblade
so this is actually believe it or not
getting to a story so blue eyeliners my
thing now and you know what I would I
decide I'm doing something I'm all-in
I am nothing if not loyal you are here
for what you I like when I decide I'm
gonna do something I do it like in
college I started with lip stain from
the body shop still wearing it 18 years
later it's never really worked for me
don't give a shit okay
I'm loyal alright like when I want
member I got into beaded belts for a
minute uh-huh then now it looks like we
belts hanging everywhere right but like
if I if I want something I want all of
them like I can't just have one of them
I am I've been a hoarder I mean I have
that hoarding nature to me didn't I do
it remember when I was in red pants oh
my god do you remember yeah forgot about
red okay yes red paid you ripped a pair
of red pants once and we had to buy like
seven more place that Turkish one pair
of red pants it's a scarcity complex
it's a deep scarcity complex that I
think I get because I remember I was a
kid and when my dad would put out a
plate of chicken nuggets I would grab
all of them and lick them all and put
them back so that no one else could have
any that's just a bright being Brad
really come play but I did it I do it
with like things that I did with horse
statues named to the clocks vaz it so
when we kept ordering different types of
soap rose soap lavender so African it
was like black African soap it was all
these things I'm like what oh yeah Froot
Loops I was like I got to the point
where I had ordered every soap on the
internet and we got to soap that had
Froot Loops like cooked in great soap by
the way so I was like I need all the
blue eyeliners this is my new thing this
is my hook my going Amazon I by NARS
eyeliner right I'm like I'm gonna buy
some nice eyeliner doing my damn thing
order it and I'm like it was weird that
it was like five dollars high weird yeah
I was like oh it's like a pandemic sale
like Jeff Bezos has finally given us a
break like he wants me to like be me he
supports my full transition into Dolly
Parton thank you sir I get it if I open
it and I'm
like you know the smell of makeup like
you know when something's off right so I
open like that doesn't smell right
it smelled like you know when you open a
box of crayons is it crowns or crayon
yeah I still don't know 33 old crayons
crowns I say crowns it's like a waxy
effluvium of like tar it's play-doh I
was like okay that doesn't smell right
and then I put it on and it was like
scratching my eyelid and like my eyes
were getting all Bernie and I had
forgotten you told me not to order
makeup off of Amazon please explain to
our listeners Hawaii first of all I love
that you still put it on even after it
smelled bad
you were like committed I honestly was
like I was too far down the road at this
point she licked it but I remember you
told me about counterfeit makeups so on
Exile I just didn't want you to be right
so badly
I'll go blind for this yeah so basically
when you order things on Amazon
unless they are licensed through Amazon
like like the Lady Gaga makeup that is
from Amazon through Amazon brand name
but in Amazon you're probably getting
your honor you're probably getting
counterfeit makeup because it's being
sold through a seller which means they
could have just had it and decided to
sell it yeah they got it it was expired
they got it like a $40 Gucci purse like
it's gonna be like a fake yeah it's fake
they have it with makeup too except
you're putting it in your like wet or
facin your first our eyes orifices are
yes they are okay see so I am putting it
on and I'm like this is burning my eye
like this isn't like I'm putting it on
I'm like why am I getting sleepy like
this can't be good like it's like
emitting like weird-ass fumes and shit I
mean a good a good rule of thumb is if
it's spelled wrong it's probably not
really and so you could just look at me
like oh this is an AR zzzzz it's just my
koala stick what it's like I don't know
there was a documentary on Netflix
called broken but it was a series and
one of them was on counterfeit makeup
and this girl had ordered all these like
makeup palettes and her eyes were like
glued shut she couldn't open it like I
don't even know what the fuck they put
in there it's like grout yeah are you
and then they just match the packaging
and you're like oh this is the same
thing but cheaper yeah yeah you got the
same thing yeah so I'm probably going to
get some kind of
like optical infection at some point but
it's worth it
and also the evolution of the vibe is
also involving these blue light glasses
these are the glasses I think we talked
about this on the show ages ago and as
usual I gave advice that I don't take
myself take and they stop the blue light
from your computer and I got a say a
Minot spunkier than I've ever been and I
feel like I've more energy since I've
been wearing them is this a placebo
effect I thought was the eyeliner though
like it's the fact that I'm in its pure
adderall I used about those Cookie
Monster balls really giving you the
energy no but I do I feel like by the
time my screen time is literally like it
is embarrassing I can't I there's
nothing I will not admit about myself
but my screen time is embarrassing at
this point and so wearing these has
really helped although the look is a
little bit terrifying I do kind of look
like a serial killer from the 70s I look
like um
join the club I know you're more 80s
yeah yeah I feel like I am doing like
the full Charlize Theron and Monster
vibes at this point when I am emotional
or wanted to I want to like fake my
death I want to change everything about
myself and I can't do that right now
because everything is closed I really
want to go get a bunch of tattoos but
tattoo borrowers are closed blah blah so
the hair is happening the blue eyeliner
is happening and then I bought all the
horse shirts on Etsy so now I moved on
to the wolf ones thank god the tattoo
shops were closed then we just go back
to that like we're really lucky that
they're not open for you right now
I really want to get a giant shark on my
forearm yeah but the way that you like
to hoard things it's a good thing that
were you just come back you're like an
aquarium so this is a very roundabout
circuitous way to get to the fact that
so this has been my vibe I found out who
I am
this is it this is my mug shot get used
to the vintage wolves get used to the
blue light glasses get used to the I
don't think this is a Karen haircut I
feel like it's not full Karen it's like
Kara it's like it's like a next ring
howdy ugly just in the background like I
do need to over to coyote ugly bar
where's the
od okay so I was flirting with my
Instagram followers as you know I am
want to do and I took a picture of
myself in my new look and I said so what
do you guys think I look like like who
do I look like right this is actually
building to something believe it or not
and you guys had hilarious fucking
comebacks is that what you even call it
someone said I look like Miss Briggs
from icarly
I don't even know about it I think
there's a hilarious first what you don't
know who iCarly no one wrote in
parenthesis the person of erotic wrote
you're gonna have to Google this you
don't know who it is you guys know me so
well and I appreciate that
Velma from scooby-doo hot take first is
that the one the orange yes that's the
smart one with the glasses we love that
that's like the Janet from Three's
Company it's an almond from scripts you
don't like you don't know Three's
Company say your first company come in
Nakano Jem and the Holograms that's my
favorite one I think I know what that is
oh yeah you looked at me you said Josie
in the Pussycat Doll you're like one of
the neighborhood wives from Edward
Scissorhands
okay plus a plus a plus you kind of like
Edward though how dare you and then
someone just wrote art Howe art Howe
that's that's that's really it though
art Howe cuz you're just like you're
just a little bit more facing away from
being a Juggalo so I'm reading these I'm
laughing I'm appreciating it we've had
an intense you know a couple weeks on
the podcast in terms of our guests and
what's going on in the world and then
some what are you guys are writing all
these hilarious things and then someone
writes you look like a comedian who
apparently doesn't make jokes anymore
ooh hot tea spilled it got her good so
the reason I'm bringing it up stupid
it's so stupid and then when I told
benjin about this but it was overload
someone writes that on every comedians
page like I didn't realize that was
something that people write on comics
pages all the time because I do that
autoblock thing fucking ages ago you
know the wire autoblock mean comments
that have certain keywords mine was like
whore and busted and old and you know
whatever so this one got through and it
you know I got to me it got to me
because I first of all I don't comments
don't hurt my feelings anymore
I am now at the point where I realized
if you make a mean comment on my page
you love me obsessed with me Europe you
love me you're in love with me and it
hurts your heart that you can't be with
me and this is the only thing you can do
to manage your pain I'm fine with mean
comments and also that's what I would do
blind people yeah totally that's what I
do what I like someone I'm gonna mean to
them so I know what you're doing I love
you too
and your dad drop the ball anyway I
really did bug me though and it did make
me want to say something because we have
Amber Riley on the podcast today and
it's an amazing interview but I did call
in legend legend and we're gonna play
she's saying freedom by Beyonce at one
of the protests and it was just unreal
and I did want to bring it up though
because I do feel like the last couple
episodes have obviously been serious
kind of reflecting what's going on in
the world and I just want to let people
know like I can't be silly in these
interviews because I do get insecure
that I'm not being funny enough but I
know what it's like to be in an
interview where the host is being really
funny and then you feel like you can't
be authentic or vulnerable like I've I
mean my whole career I've had to go into
like radio interviews and morning show
interviews and podcast interviews were
you walking in someone's okay weird you
coming Google come on your face come on
my tits would come on my ass and then I
have to like you yeah come on the church
like then I have to adapt to the tone
they're setting yeah you think that
that's the tone of the show now and you
just become a different person
I love monster truck truck a comb up
into my butt and you're like that's not
what I wanted to do here today like
that's not why I drove here so like this
is a delicate time and I think that in
order to get the kind of interviews
we're getting I can't just be goofy you
the whole time you know a game that
people have their space to talk about
what they want to talk about yeah just
giving them a platform for all these
people to listen to you and the reason I
need to air this resentment is because I
know the type of bitch I am and I what
I'll do is I'll hold in the resentment
and not say anything about it and then
one day I'll just be like I'll just quit
the podcast like we're done now like I'm
not doing this anymore like I have to
let it out because I do I know things
are I think the pocket is evolving you
know and I think it's time I love having
my comedian friends on and we will
always do that don't panic
we had you come down yeah okay everyone
that's okay how come this doesn't have
you know your money comic friend they
all have for podcasts if you want to
hear Bobby Lee or Chris D'Elia you can
hear them anytime you want you know you
don't have to come here for them but I
do uh I we had done Jim Jefferies his
second round don't worry we talked about
threesomes for about an hour that's
gonna come out very soon that would have
been a weird to drop that two weeks ago
would have been just bizarre
and then next week I'm actually really
excited we're gonna have dr. David agus
on professor of medicine and engineering
at the University of Southern California
and he I'm so afraid I'm not gonna be
able pronounce this co-founder of
Navigenics a personalized medicine
company and applied proteomics which is
proteomics is a large-scale study of
shit and we love that you guys know that
I love true science Benton I think we're
evolving into actually talking to
legitimate scientists instead of Benton
being like yeah I read that somewhere
once so far haven't been wrong I did
read all those things and so I think
it's important to like read the room you
know in terms of like I noticed that
with everything that's going on and
you'll see someone's like Instagram
you're like oh this bitch is just not
reading the room yeah not she's not
aware yeah yeah and so I you know I just
want to acknowledge that because I just
want you guys to know that I know and
and I'm I think that when we started
this podcast we wanted it to be
educational funny but also you're gonna
learn something about yourself you're
gonna learn new vocabulary you're gonna
you be inspired like that's always what
we want to do this podcast but the
problem is all my friends are hilarious
comedians so we did sort of you know it
is it is kind of hard to go back and
forth so expect more and expect
different yeah and so I just I love that
I'm spending 20 minutes acknowledging
one troll that was probably drunk when
he wrote one comment and it's controlled
the last five days my but here's your
moment sir and then yeah so I also like
I mean this is what we wanted to make a
podcast that was like if you only listen
to one podcast a week like this will be
yeah you'll walk away with was a joke
you can share with your friends and
information I was gonna say like if you
only have one hour week to listen to a
podcast listen this one you only have
six hours because that's a no one five
you
five hours Baggins ever been a Viking
hour so anyway amber Riley's coming up
you know her from Glee you know her she
played Effie and dream girls on the West
and she's I mean truly truly I still
watch Glee to this day yeah and The Wiz
you've seen her she's incredible
and she comes on and it totally blew my
mind is a powerful speaker yes marked
that's coming up and it's definitely a
balance like you know we were able to
find I think a lot of comedy and the
tension of what's going on why don't I
never say comedy in tension why don't I
never say that again so let's just a
couple updates about touring touring LOL
you guys remember that remember touring
memory one I left my house I missed
touring so much I the reason that I have
not said anything about it is that I
just don't know I'd never changing I
literally don't know every time we
reschedule the tour everything changes I
don't want anyone's grandmother to get
sick because they came to one of my
shows a lot of the venues are making the
calls here a lot of people that work at
these venues are getting furloughed I
mean it's it's devastating it's a wild
time thank you for your patience they're
always gonna be updates on the website
when you guys text me I really
appreciate it 3 2 don't pay one eight
eight one eight to thirty seven seventy
five to seven I will try to respond
Benton you're gonna send out updates
today generally two people on that so
text on that in Benton's gonna do
updates by city Los Angeles the Largo
shows those are postponed Huntington New
York was canceled again these are not I
do not make these decisions we're going
to find new venues to do Montclair New
Jersey is canceled San Francisco is
cancelled we're gonna move to a new
venue Indianapolis is canceled such a
bummer
San Francisco what's that I thought that
was st. okay sorry that was the second
show Miami August 22nd I'm apparently in
Miami Oklahoma
Miami sorry the fuckin name it Atlanta
it looks like we're doing that on
September 24th Boston Massachusetts
October 22nd mance
mash the hana Tucket Connecticut what is
it Matt mash mash on it what is it
Mashantucket I've done that the Fox with
so many times and I still don't know I
become illiterate in the last three
months
October 23rd that's happening Nashville
is happening November 7th
this is updated right yeah that's from
today I printed off your okay Atlantic
City November 14th is happening spend
Thanksgiving with me Anaheim is
happening January 9th
Orlando January 16th Clearwater Florida
Scientologists come through Guthrie 17th
Minneapolis January 20th okay so in
January I'm doing a bunch of dates
Minneapolis were doing two shows it
looks like on January 23rd at the
Pantages Theatre Ridgefield Connecticut
we're doing it February 5th and six two
shows Houston Texas yes I mean Houston
was the second show we canceled after
Detroit remember mm-hmm was the first
one I know Detroit
oh that's coming up not Detroit we woke
April 16th that's rescheduled March 20th
is Dallas Texas Chicago Illinois
April 10th two shows that night
Cleveland April 17th Sacramento coming
at you May 15th and all this is on
Whitney Cummings common yeah look at it
yourself so sorry if you guys have been
annoying and frustrating if you're not
getting refunds I'm trying like I just I
don't control all of that like I bear
like bear I don't know where my
headphones are today like I just dull
this is text Benson yeah okay you have
anything else you need to say because I
guess we have Mert new merch we have new
merch and I'll be honest I've had shame
about promoting March given everything
that's going on in the world but I'm
holding it's true but we still have it
regard that keeps yelling at me that I'm
not wearing it enough we have new merch
it's for pride it's for charity it's
being done after the black trans and
Finn's in the arts fund can you say that
again what train but bathroom fast the
arts faster five times you can get that
store thought Whitney Cummings calm it's
real good real cute real nice we have
this real cool hoodie that you're
wearing I'll on the back I would turn
around but it says you engage can you
swivel for us good for you on the back
of it yeah so the merch is all we need
to start doing blue light glasses mark
we're doing more masks merch we're gonna
do some up bat birds by popular demand
we won't have more merch coming but
right now get to March we have that's
not worried about we have in the future
we have this right now okay
please enjoy Amber Riley thank you bye
don't mind elephants oh yeah
you